this is WWE immortals this is a exciting
fighting action game on mobile platforms
with the strategy of a collectible card
game on top of it
so I'm gonna jump in here right into my
ladders the normal progression of the
game you'll be working away through
ladders with the initial characters you
have I'm gonna find out harder battle
there I've leveled up my guys a little
bit let's go up this ladder here and my
team here consists of the demon Kane the
Centurion version of Roman reigns and
the dark sorceress version of Paige
we've got multiple variations of each
character who have their own unique
moves so I'm starting right off with my
big guy Kane starting off with some of
his light attacks so all of our moves
were captured for us fresh specifically
for this game by professional wrestling
motion capture artists to capture the
flavor of each of the wrestlers so that
proper training the Superstars and divas
from the WWE but taking it over the top
as good as the Superstars and divas are
they can't set people on fire like Cain
has no I was talking enough paying
attention so I got Kane knocked out but
Roman reigns has come in and I'm gonna
activate one of his signatures a
Superman punch there so I mean I've got
a fighting mechanic here that I'm using
taps and swipes that are appropriate to
the mobile platform all right so I see
that Triple H has three adrenaline bars
built up and so that's time to bring in
his finisher you know this is obviously
this is out of the ring and these are
fantastical versions of the WWE
Superstars interiors that you know and
love
and that's let us take these you know
take these over the top we've got rules
here that are all based on the real news
they use in the ring but they're taken
to that next level they're taking these
you know setting people on fire punching
them up into the air so there we go
I won that time earned a bunch of XP
earned some credits that now I can take
those credits and I can go visit the
store so in the store I can buy booster
packs where I can get a random character
I can also buy a specific character
we've got 26 cards in the game at launch
and we've got more coming all the time a
great problem to have when working with
the WWE is that they have such an
amazing history and so many incredible
personalities it was very very difficult
to narrow down to just this many
characters and everybody internally at
the studio had everybody had favorites
that they were fighting to get on the
list we've also got talent cards that
boost up your characters so go take a
look at my collection I've been playing
for a little while so I've got everybody
unlocked but we can go in to any of
these cards you can take a look and
there's a lot of different ways to level
up your character leveling up you earn
XP and that improves the stats of your
character there's also no waste to
getting an extra card in a booster pack
because you can improve the rank of your
character which also boosts their stats
you can also specifically go into their
signatures and finishers and spend the
credits to boost them up and every
character has a every version of a
character has a unique passive ability
so John Cena here does more damage as he
loses the health he's got the will to
win the other version of John Cena we
have in the game John John Cena has a
different path
right after he tags in his nest but next
special attack a signature or finisher
he's going to do 20 percent additional
damage we've also got unique moves for
the different variations of the
characters for their signature tubes for
combo Enders and we've also got an
exciting feature called chemistry that
draws on the history of alliances and
rivalries that we've had in the WWE for
years and so every character has
potential allies and potential rivals
putting potential allies on your team
gives everybody a health and attack
boost which is a you know just a win but
putting rivals on their team gives
everybody a knock to their defense but
it increases their adrenaline
regeneration which lets you hit those
special attacks more often so I like to
say it's spurring each other to
greatness if you're on a team with
rivals you want to show off for them so
it's a riskier strategy but an
aggressive player might find it
interesting we've also got gear that you
can get in the game and you can get gear
by completing ranking in multiplayer
leaderboards you can also purchase gear
booster packs and these are items that
will power up your character in a
variety of ways so that was WWE
immortals coming January 15th to Android
and iOS devices
you